come va selezionatori vorrei raccontarvi la
mia storia su YouTube prima di tutto
lasciate che ve lo presenti questo se sei un
uomo di cultura sai che questa non è
una base ma è una chitarra assicurati di
guardare tutto il video per un  rivelazione di suonare la chitarra
alla fine di questo video
lasciami spiegare mio padre è un musicista ha
suonato il piano per tutta la vita
voleva che suonassi uno strumento così quando
avevo 15 anni mi ha regalato una chitarra
e poi quello che ho  fatto ovviamente ho
iniziato a giocare ai videogiochi su YouTube
scelta saggia ahah all'inizio il
mio canale ha iniziato a crescere così velocemente
in poco tempo sono diventata la prima
youtuber italiana ma quando Marzia ha iniziato a fare
video tutti i fan hanno iniziato a
sostenermi per farla  il primo
youtuber italiano al mondo
sorprendentemente l'anno scorso Matt ha selezionato
YouTube così sono diventato di nuovo il primo
youtuber italiano mi sento bene proprio da
ragazzi purtroppo non sono più il primo
youtuber italiano perché alcuni giorni fa
non so se y  lo conosci ma c'è il giro di un
ragazzo nel ritmo che
mi ha superato in questi sette anni di
youtube non ho mai suonato la chitarra è
perché mi stavo concentrando sui miei video
negli ultimi due anni sono un affare misericordioso
e ho iniziato a concentrarmi su  la mia vita sui miei
amici sulla mia famiglia e ho anche un
creatore di video ora lasciami modificare i miei video
ma non questo scacco matto YouTuber che
non modificano i propri video OMG ma ora
ragazzi prestate attenzione alcuni giorni fa mio padre ha
reagito a david phi  prima e questa è stata
la reazione di cosa è orgoglioso di lui
invece di me devo fare qualcosa per
questa situazione se sei un seguace di
Davey Phi prima di sapere che
odia i chitarristi scacco matto chitarristi
bene bene sfidano prima che iniziassi a
suonare il  chitarra nelle ultime due settimane
e ho imparato una canzone che descrive perfettamente il
mio stato d'animo dopo il tuo signore Paso
ma onestamente non riesco a ricordare come
suonarla forse se hai dormito come ora
posso ricordare cosa vuoi che suoni
questa canzone
ok Davi  d questo è per te ti mostrerò il
mio vero talento
[musica]
ciao oscurità il mio vecchio amico
di nuovo
[musica]
è incosciente
[musica] il
mio cervello mi guida i brividi
diamo un altro
scacco matto
taniyama tutto il meglio che non ha  qualsiasi
emozione ma ragazzi questo è solo l'
inizio molto molto presto passerò
alla base e poi si sfidano prima che
vi sfiderò a una battaglia di base così posso
sicuramente loro in coda che io
canale Lamarr non riguarda i sottomarini non
si tratta  le visualizzazioni non riguarda la
pagina e non riguarda il mio creatore di video,
sto scherzando ma riguarda il fatto che
mio padre è finalmente orgoglioso di me comunque
ragazzi ha portato alla mia attenzione che
prima si sfidano è
maledetto è fortunato a indossare  le sue cuffie
e io conosco questa maledizione è davvero davvero
molto doloroso, si spera che se parli
italiano nei tuoi video non vieni
colpito da questa maledizione quindi l'ho
evitato possono togliermi facilmente le cuffie
ma la fibra quotidiana in realtà non può quindi per
favore  ragazzi iscrivetevi ora alla fibra quotidiana
per aiutarmi a togliermi le cuffie
e ora prima della fine di questo
video è finalmente un momento terribile
gioco terapia tempo puoi iniziare da ora
Non mi arrendo a questo
suona come
se non lo fosse  figo a
chi frega un cazzo
carino
tu
OMG